the army has released the names of two  soldiers killed by a roadside bomb in  Afghanistan over the weekend  mayor Staff Sergeant Ian McLaughlin of  Newport News Virginia and private first  class Miguel V alone of Joliet Illinois  both were on their first combat  deployment when they were hit by an AED  in Kandahar province the Taliban has  claimed responsibility for the attack in  a new interview with Axios national  security advisor Robert O'Brien says the  u.s. is now back in talks with the  Taliban after negotiations had stalled  in September he says the president may  reduce the American presence in  Afghanistan this year even without a  deal  you